the Town Center challenge fund is
looking at how we can help fall of the
small Market towns to review what
they're doing and see how they can take
their towns forward during covid many of
us experienced problems the business
says have had to learn how to to work
differently and part of this project is
to actually look at that what needs to
happen in those towns to change to meet
the needs of the new community be that
business youth or just us and our
visitor economy these Market towns on
the whole are very very attractive they
have some great assets
and they really really ought to be
somewhere that we can go and visit so
it's about how those towns can sell
those assets and that's what this
funding is allowing there's a whole host
of recommendations which you'll see
throughout this video as the four towns
themselves present their issues and
their Solutions
foreign
[Music]
market and we're looking at creative
wayfinding and place making within the
town center and our external gateways
leading into the Town Center Stone
Market unique in itself but it gets
forgotten quite a lot of the time and
missed it has very passionate people and
community so we commissioned
counterculture who are specialist
Consultants around strategy and place
making counterculture are really great
at coming into the town center and
really engaging with as many people as
possible for the consultation process to
have as many voices heard we held a
stone Market what's next event for
people to find out what was going on
there was a really strong Community
voice and I think in terms of delivery
for this project that's really key going
forwards some of the key recommendations
that are coming from this report really
are around the key gateways in terms of
our the station and accessibility
cycling routes walking routes as well in
the town center and reaching out to
those green areas the Food Museum coming
up as a key element of Stone Market and
really promote that another
recommendation is around the market as
one of our Market towns you really want
to promote that and make sure that it is
bustling and booming and really
revitalizing Our Town centers our
Consultants have broken down some of the
findings and how we can Implement those
in the town center and working with
locals and our other community groups
and organizations they're already doing
great work and working together to
deliver this plan embedded in the future
growth of Stone Market this project
really is around bringing the pool of
resources that are already together for
a really strong development plan to
improve the growth and investment and
popularity of Stone Market as a great
place to live and work and visit
[Music]
so this project is called
it's called it's a partnership project
with the LEP and e-suffic Council and
First Light Festival where we've been
doing some scoping work in framlingham
looking at how young people currently
engage with the Town Center working out
what they would like to see and leading
to them contributing to future plans for
young people in the town one of the
things that they said they really would
like to see in the Town Center was live
music gigs opportunities to meet so
that's how this project came about that
we've now organized this event with them
to enjoy and hopefully excite them about
coming and doing more in the Town Center
so I think it's great and it will be
really interesting to see how it goes to
see if it makes them feel more connected
to the town and then we'll be able to
feed back to the stakeholders in the
town future of our towns really sits
with the younger generation and so it's
thinking of inventive ways of making
them feel engaged and that the place
actually belongs to them as well
a lot of people realize that being with
each other and having an experience is
probably one of the best things that can
happen to us as humans and that they
bring the town alive I hope there'll be
more and and maybe we'll be able to help
more people you know facilitate more in
a similar way in different towns
[Music]
it is an ancient town with a market at
its heart as a local Center it was
already under a threat from some macro
changes covert really exacerbated that
and we saw a very sharp rise in vacancy
rates the whole of the High Street the
viability of it was in serious question
so in this way we were seeking ways that
we could possibly redress the balance
and to nudge what and back to being a
vibrant Town Center so we'd already been
able to
carry out extensive engagements with the
community in a project which we call
Future breckland the consultation has
involved thousands of voices from
Wharton this challenge fund sets out a
vision for Wharton over the next 10
years
first to turn temporary public spaces
into new permanent quality public spaces
second by taking out parking and roads
without impinging on how the High Street
would operate the challenge fund has
shown us the way so I sincerely believe
here what we have created is a blueprint
for a market town of the 21st Century
and my dear hope is that we can roll
this out across the whole country
and that Wharton becomes a pilot
our project is followed on from
um some extensive regeneration work
that's going on in North Walsham and
that involves improvements to the
marketplace and building improvements
and improvements to access to the town
and that's through things like Lopes and
various Pathways that lead into the Town
Center our part of the project involves
a vision and marketing exercise that's
going to look at how the town can
capitalize on those improvements and
take forward a kind of vision for the
town for the next five years the most
interesting conversations we've had have
actually been with the young people so
we went into the high school and we did
a series of focus groups they are very
clear on what they want their town to
look like so we have a youth club that's
opening in the Town Center what we would
like to see now is a number of
businesses creating some apprenticeship
and work experience schemes for young
people to try and keep Talent within the
town community so that's going to be a
major change and Improvement especially
for young people and also we have looked
at various actual tangible events so
that you've got people coming into the
town but also the people who live and
work in that town have sense of pride in
it North Walsham it has so much
potential in in terms of its location
its history its diverse Community there
is opportunity here for this town to
really put itself on the map